have you seen this video speaking of no
what is it is the bum in your car
no wait place video connect I just say
some real quick yeah I got a brand new
iPhone pro 11 max whatever ad for ammo
so you remember out my phone went off
last week and then today yes there's a
first time out of breast you ever strike
so last week Dave Rubin had a heart out
so I said alarm okay turn all the way
down
apparently the alarm doesn't turn all
the way down because I'm alarm no this
is this new phone can do no work today
try to send this video and then the
video went off when I was sending it cuz
you're not used to it yeah that's all
it's a cool thing that's gonna slap you
if it goes this is kind of inspiration
what is this I don't know Brian see
let's change the ouvea B oh did you send
it to me oh yeah I just thought it was
the only you're driving your buddies
keep taxing you know how they call it
get to it yeah that's why I haven't
gotten to it well some you me and Brogan
we have a thread and it's like all [ __ ]
you should definitely click on yeah but
when I'm driving my car get to it then I
forget yeah and I'll send something
wrong like can't you [ __ ] see why
Center on it oh yeah my bad yeah all
right here we go how much how much how
much different 40 bucks per person do y
sorry do all right you know both you
guys off for 40 bucks
all right we're asking about weed what
what is that that Jonah Hill it looked
like it was the house man
what was that be well again it's just
driving how much how much different 40
bucks per person do y sorry
do all right you know I'll suck both you
guys off for 40 bucks
all right we're asked about weed no I
don't know what's going on I'm confused
too how much and the guy goes what
[ __ ] how much he goes 40 bucks 40
bucks but first I'll suck you both off
boy bucks person and they were like no
we were talking about weed yeah do you
know him no somebody sent that oh poor
guy this is real oh yeah let's block it
let's let's blur his face
I thought that was viral all right
didn't any smother his friend or didn't
Eddie send that to us
all right let's edit that out there well
you gotta leave it now fantastic no you
people got no over talking about those
terrible bright Oh
I've sent that to me I think it was a so
why did you do that to us
explain yourself that was funny you
thought that was funny if we knew him
it'd be funny
feels like south so do Sasser yeah and I
said well where is this that was Jonah
Hill had been funny
it looks like Johnny L it does a little
bit hey hey that's not the video I was
gonna have you sent anyway maybe you're
better than this I thought it was no
comedy I thought it was funny yeah maybe
in the text then it is funny cuz
employers can be plural of course yeah
we got to leave it cos face I want the
fans to realize what I went through
right now why is that so bad they just
you know that's that's it this stuff we
talk about all the time I know but we
don't know him that happens all the time
I think what I mean it happens all the
time you know where they were dry by the
way that's a video Brian said to me like
on last week but we never got to play it
that's why I sent it over I know right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]